Vanessa Bryant is filing a wrongful
death lawsuit
ETS learned the lawsuit is against
Island Express the company that owned
the doomed helicopter that crashed on
January 26 killing her husband Kobe
Bryant their 13 year old daughter Gianna
and seven others who were traveling to
the momba Academy in Thousand Oaks
California according to legal documents
obtained by et Vanessa is claiming that
the aircraft and pilot were negligent
and that the chopper was unsafe
helicopter to echo x-ray a proof it are
you transitioning and VFR condition VFR
condition for 1500 strictly the lawsuit
alleges that the helicopter was only
allowed to fly under visual flight rules
and on the day of the crash conditions
were not conducive for such flying VFR
as visual flight rules meaning that
you're flying visually references
singing mountains according to the suit
the pilot era George sabayon was
traveling at 180 miles per hour in heavy
fog in a steep decline allegations
against abuyin also include failing to
properly assess weather conditions and
failing to maintain control of the
aircraft we're not just focusing on
weather here though we take a broad look
at everything around an investigation
and around an accident we look at
man-machine and the environment and
weather is just a small portion of that
what's more the lawsuit also claims that
sabayon was previously disciplined in
2015 for violating the visual flight
rules by flying into an airspace of
reduced visibility Vanessa is asking for
punitive damages several people called
911 fetal crash on January 26th the LA
County Fire Department leader released
five of those calls which shed light on
how poor the weather conditions were our
helicopters the ones that are long beach
that are this the patrol helicopters
they're smaller they only seat four
passengers and they do not do
instrumentation flight they have to do
visual flight only so if it's to be if
it's less than 2,000 feet visibility
they're just not taking off what's more
the LAPD revealed in a press conference
that they had grounded their fleet of
helicopters on the morning of the crash
due to heavy fog which didn't meet their
minimum standards for flying